better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours our
listeners get 10 off the first month at
betterhelp.com trash tuesday our show is
sponsored by helix mattresses which we
are obsessed with i am a very particular
sleeper i run hot and i only sleep on my
side so helix mattress has the specific
type of mattress for someone like me and
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
trash tuesday you guys manskit has these
really soft buttery boxers that i am
absolutely obsessed with they are super
breathable and i want your balls to
breathe this summer this is essential to
life you guys go get these boxers
they're made from micro modal fabric and
they are so so soft i'm obsessed with
them and you guys can get 20 off plus
free shipping with our code trash
manscaped.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with our code trash
manscaped.com hello sluggies boy
sluggies girl sluggies mama sluggies
grandma sluggies i've met you i see what
you're up to i want to meet more of you
i love you it's been amazing come see me
on the road i will be next in west
niagara new york this very weekend i
can't wait that's the 24th through the
25th
please come to that please enjoy my new
merch um the tickets were
a lot
uh then i'm taking july off you can then
see me after that in austin texas
springfield missouri pittsburgh improv
tempe arizona colusa california
kansas city missouri irvine california
michigan i got a whole bunch of other
dates i rescheduled the ones i missed
just go to andyletterman.com
joe's i am uh
also doing stand-up less so this summer
but
esteronice.com for tickets i think we've
got dc and austin see you guys
is this a sex cult
the swim club i know that
not that i knew of
mark i want to ask you something so
we're all beautiful what's up mark how
are you good thanks for coming you're
welcome look at everybody in the daytime
i feel like i'm the only one who didn't
nail the shoe game i feel like you did
shaved though i hardly probably the only
one yeah
maron you have like no hair on your legs
what's up with that i'm not that hairy
what happened to your knee
that was uh yeah
yeah
what happened was cleaning my no i
wasn't sucking dick i was cleaning
do you live in the same place uh i live
in glendale i don't know which place you
went to okay yeah i think you went you
were at the old place it was nice esther
see my new place yeah nicer much nicer
yeah wow you were in the little old
place with the cave white garage there
was a garage but it didn't seem like a
little place it was a pretty beautiful
nice it's a cute place right but it's up
on the hill
yeah no i got a new house cool and i was
cleaning the porch on my hands and knees
and i scraped my knees wow what a man i
love that love you have the paper towel
for him what do you have the tape to
roll for him oh get it ready what tape
from our last from our episode are we
sure we want to do this it's
embarrassing it'll be funny
it'll embarrass everyone here it's
embarrassing to me
you'll like it oh
you might be embarrassed though
and annie said i'm supposed to be
wearing the flower i don't really know
dude that's so good i was just trying to
do something i think this was a good i
think
well kalylah i walked in and she's like
esther this looks it this look fits you
so well and i was like oh it's a
compliment and then she's like you look
like jesus and i'm like that's not a cop
no actually you do know jesus trio you
look just like him
no you do look like you would be in a
cult 100
because i'm so ready willing they would
kick your ass out so fast they would be
like you're so annoying she'd be
complaining how cold it was and stuff
oh no she'd probably be wouldn't you
eventually just start caring about
everybody yeah
i think so i need your headphones for
this yes
do i want my headphones is this a game
are we playing something no they just
mentioned you in a past episode a couple
weeks ago and they want to shoot and
annie wants to hear that it's gonna be
embarrassing for everyone
i can't
honestly maybe they're my second is
controversial next to bobby okay and um
i just find him to be i i have this is
not controversial rooting kind of like a
[ __ ] this life [ __ ] everyone and that's
mark mary
honestly maybe there's a hair situation
i don't know what it is then i start
talking about something and mark okay we
love him okay lynn his dearly dream
you're talking about your dead
girlfriend okay it's okay it's okay
absolutely
unbelievable
just everything we used to talk in the
green room like why is he getting like
hot he's so mad
why is he hotter
there was this one episode he did uh i
wouldn't actually
did it
ratakowski oh yeah
is that when lynn died she just passed
away immediately yeah when she saw it
out of chicago
oh i know
yeah that was the joe swanberg show
right yeah i did i did one episode every
three you know for three seasons it was
an anthology show but the ratakowski was
that was crazy
when they did they cast her first
i don't know like i actually didn't even
know who she was because i'm an idiot
and swanberg's like you're gonna like
this episode i'm like
because emily rodakowski's in i'm like i
gotta look her up and i was like okay
but i didn't know what that meant
uh and then it was just one of those
weird kind of uh you know what what did
we do that conversation you have with
somebody before you do a scene like that
you got to be pretty specific what kind
of well esther the guy didn't he like
didn't he like call out sick when he had
to she does a bit about that don't you
do it
no i figured yeah right from the
headlines
that is true that when i had a intimate
scene the my part my scene partner was
unavailable
suddenly
but you know let's go back to mark's
story
i've done a couple of those but with
emily it was you just kind of talk it
out and yeah i couldn't believe it was
happening she's pretty stunning yeah
yeah she's like the prettiest woman
around i'm probably around i would say
yeah what was the conversation like
because i i imagine you have to be very
careful of making her feel comfortable
but also right like well i mean
i think most
productions have like an intimacy person
now yeah um but that was not that one i
thought they put him in jail wasn't that
harvey weinstein
no like like somebody who makes every
sure everything's okay
an intimacy coordinator they needed to
make an intimacy course we had one on
doll face i never took their calls i was
like i got this
what are the parameters like what are
the guidelines
i think it's a negotiation or it's a
conversation that needs to be
facilitated between the two people and
then they they have to feel safe but i
mean with emily and i was sort of like
what do you want to do because it wasn't
full-on nudity but it was sort of like
can i you know kind of touch your boobs
are we kissing
wait have you ever done anything that's
not one syllable glow marin easy marin
is two cylinders
there's one word one word so one word
you can change it
well i forgot what a syllable was
also why would syllable be two that's
true we're learning syllables next on
next week's episode thank you did i
really teach bobby how to read a clock
you really did that's crazy you know
that bobby didn't know how to read time
online with regular i can relate to that
i don't know why you guys are laughing
and
shaming the special the same reason that
you didn't know what syllables were i
know i'm sorry
did you skip elementary school though
i did i did but i was smoking cigarettes
in the bathroom but are you similar to
bobby where it's like if you didn't
catch it the first time you're just
gonna double down and say [ __ ] it i'm
never gonna learn it or do you continue
to try because with bobby it was more
like ah well you know digital watches
are available so i'm you know at 13 he
then decided that [ __ ] it i'm just never
going to be that guy who reads and that
gave him a major breakthrough that guy
you really did
there's like a shame level but i feel
like bobby like i feel like you may have
shamed him in the situation maybe bobby
liked the shame i remember learning
things like like the clock hands and
stuff and it was the whole school and
then they would go all right it's your
turn what time is it and the panic of
like
being accumulated in front of the class
i didn't like that i feel like bobby
would have like maybe gotten a boner or
something oh um with the shame yeah i
don't think i shamed him i was just sort
of like come on yeah i guess that's
shame
come on stupid
it's your language that's your love
language oh my god wait maybe you could
teach me how to swim with those tactics
that takes patience and you gotta really
you know it's a there's um yeah i can't
believe you don't notice i want to throw
you in like a baby you know they thought
babies can swim you know that right you
can start with a board you know are you
afraid to get in the water are you do
you freak out i'm a little nervous she's
afraid her pubes will get caught in the
bottom if i can't touch how's that gonna
happen
so long
did you flash me yesterday
oh
it's just
it's a grooming issue
okay well it's on both ends
she hasn't groomed herself i love you i
thought i think esther's been grooming
both of us this whole time yeah you are
the teal swan do you not know who she is
can you pull her up carlos there's a
documentary about this woman on free
form
and she said that mockingly because the
only other thing we've ever seen on
freeborn was esther's show thank you but
um she has this massive following i do
think some of the things that she says
is pretty enlightening but i think her
people are freaked out by the fact that
she would fit the uh the you know usual
description of a cult leader
and what's so wrong about that i know
all right listen every cult documentary
i watch about the two episodes and i'm
like this is a good cult and then you
get to the third one and something gets
a little rough but the not and the
inauguration of it but how like
indoctrination desperate and gullible do
you have to be to really lock into that
[ __ ] i mean like that much i don't know
man if i go if like within three or four
days if it's really not sticking with me
i'll be like this [ __ ]
yeah like someone's got to be really
good they've got to have
like major mental problems you know to
get through to me has anyone ever
yeah i wonder if you're like cause you
know doug stand up surrounded by just
like absolutely insane people but that's
like his happy place yeah well he
likes that yeah exactly but do you think
that um that you could ever be gotten by
or have you ever been gotten by a
psychic like is that anyone giving you
like uh well i have to i have to because
my boundaries are so shitty i have to
actively kind of push back on that [ __ ]
yeah because yeah i want to believe it
you know i i wouldn't got a booster
today but there was part of me my second
booster but there was part of me that
sort of like i don't need it like i have
it like they're like i will get suckered
in to aggravated belief systems yeah but
and i have to literally say dude you
know because it feels good it feels good
to like yeah i want to believe the
psychic yeah one guy i went to uh
oh i think it kind of ended when i was
driving i
went to school in boston and we were
driving down to new york and we stopped
in bridgeport and there was a pt barnum
museum in bridgeport this creepy place
it's a circus museum yeah and the guy
who worked there had one eye
and i wonder if he did that to get the
job probably but anyway so he like i'm
walking out and he says i'm a psychic
and he grabs my hand and he looks at me
you're gonna get into a bad accident oh
i hate that when they do a negative one
it's like what the [ __ ] that was but
that was like the only thing he said so
for like a decade
no it isn't that long i had a neighbor i
had a neighbor who was a a psychic she
was really
and she would say things all the time
like
when i really started to realize it was
crazy it wasn't she i i needed to like
fact something and she was like don't
walk to the fedex whatever you do don't
walk to the fedex place i'm like it's
two blocks are some things and she goes
i don't know she goes no use this app no
she wanted to control me with her
psychic powers like she wanted me to
think and i had an app it required a nap
that doesn't seem psychic before you
could like
where you could back stuff she's like
just do it from here and i was like no
[ __ ] i want to she's like use my coupon
code like i was gonna get killed yeah
she was a [ __ ] she sounds like she
just sounds like my mom my mom was the
biggest fear monger of all like the
first time i ever decided okay like i'm
20 years old 21 i'm gonna go to a club
she's it's gonna burn down have you not
heard about that club in brazil like
always she like pulls and extracts every
bad tragedy and she uses it as an
example for why i shouldn't step out the
door she's she
uh transfers her fear onto you all of it
i like flying everything my mom when
carlos and i drove from skokie to gigs
in indianapolis she was like be careful
of fire crashes we're like we've never
heard of that what is that
i don't meteor i think it's when a car
hits another car and they explode yeah
really i guess like she saw it in a
movie i think with parents they need to
like she saw the movie crash
it with parents they i think they should
have like a tiny bit of that because if
they don't have that it's almost like
fair but not too much well my um my best
friend who was the least afraid totally
type a adrenaline junkie type of girl
when she had a kid after she had her
first born she's like something changed
i am the most terrified person in the
world
yeah it's a constant worry and um yeah
she she is afraid for her child or
anything that may go and maybe you gotta
be careful with that my parents are like
that i think they mistook worrying and
panic for love and then you're just sort
of an extension of their fear and it
becomes a real nightmare yeah it sounds
like her
youtube my exact same well that's why i
can't do the you know the sidekick or
anything i've got to like just not do it
because i want to believe who doesn't
want to [ __ ] believe if you think
like especially if you're missing a
chunk of your sense of self
you know if somebody's willing to
provide you guidance of any kind you're
like no that sounds pretty always yeah
you're like in a low place when you go
to a psychic like you're like liminal
space you're always in an in between how
are they not just like
what are they fronts for you you can
tell me all these like weird little
psychics and in their little houses
are like doing
amazing business why do they always look
like that like if i were a psychologist
i would change like like
a brand rebrand like this sure well
we're in the outfits that's true i we
were recently at whitney's house and she
had like a random girl there who did
like a reading for us
whitney always has a random girl
doesn't she have many are there always
all kinds of rando's there doing
something is that a cult just a guy
putting a light in what's that guys
but like i she's still starting to call
trying to i relate to what you're saying
like about wanting to believe because i
definitely don't believe in any of that
stuff but when they're reading it and
telling you about you i literally get
tingles like it feels good when they're
looking at those cards they're like okay
here we go that was the girl she hired
to finger you while you were getting the
reading who did she hire to finger you
esther i know she didn't even you were
invited i was invited but i am a hermit
mark you are yeah
i i don't go out much why um
outside of the water i generally just
like hate people in the world yeah she
likes the fish but she also kills them
it's right i do kill fish but it's weird
in l.a what are you gonna do though like
during the day like i spend my day i go
to supermarkets then i cook things and
then i'll just wander places to get one
thing but you want your place let's see
yeah that's the difference you actually
step out like after this i might go get
a squash
where
esther
i know we're like literally have the
same blood yeah like me and esther i
don't want to point out the obvious yeah
i think but yeah
[Laughter]
we know it rhymes with hoodaism
[Laughter]
i know like
when we're on the road together i do
just feel like we're family like in some
way there's a familial cause he's not
trying to bang you like every other
comic
we need one comic to hit on you that's
gotta happen
do they still
no not on comics no do they still well
she says they've never no well a few she
dated there was just a famous incident
on our show where a comic hit on both of
them and didn't hit on me and so yeah
i'm now how'd that go for that guy
not well
things are finally simmering down we
think
oh my god we haven't gotten a true
lawsuit
we're not going to court so that's a
good thing that's good so no going
outside no like i go outside a lot for
like nature stuff like hiking and where
do you hike
everywhere yeah yeah do you ever go over
there by in glendale at the brand
library i've been to that one that's
where i go like two three times a week
up that thing i like that one i go
everywhere i go to malibu i go
that's a whole day
not really there's no time you leave
know people always ask me when because
if they don't live there like you go to
the beach like never never it's like a
[ __ ] i got to bring a tent you guys
are the same people why a tent
it's so far away no i mean it's just
like it's a joke i mean like i got a
camp because it's going to take me a day
to get oh i thought it was a sun
exposure no no no no no it's like it's
such a big commitment to get to well
esther's like where would the food be
where it is
you need it to be like a field trip
where there's a teacher with you that
has like snacks cooler stuff like that
yeah who's got the cooler yes is there
cold cuts
it's a field trip yeah yeah it's like a
whole thing i need a permission slip i
live near the beach and never go but
when i go other places where there's a
beach i enjoy the beach i was like the
beach is great i gotta when i go home i
gotta check this out
i like the beach pretty good but i don't
love it some people love it
i go to hawaii sometimes kawaii kawaii
is great right
we went to oahu together in it
why did you bring up hawaii we barely
came back friends really barely the
three of you went to travel yeah it was
our first travel and you did it for the
show yeah yeah
there was a did the numbers go bigger no
annie left early let's just say you
know
but in a funny way i irish could buy the
whole trip what does that mean
instead of just taking a plane back from
kauai to the maynard which boyfriend was
this the skateboarder the one now no no
that was a rollerblader
my asian okay um i met this guy yeah
he's a nice guy he's a good one but we
instead of just going back to oahu we
flew all the way home yeah and then we
just sent a picture from home and we
knew that esther would be very jealous
because an esther move yeah you didn't
like it there
it was raining the whole time it was a
pretty rainy trip i just i like going
places but i really like going home so
the fact that she
beat me to it i was like that should
have been my movie we thought you were
gonna be on the plane like maybe you
should just you know go places like
drive and just decide when to turn
around for the good part
that would be fun
[Music]
now a word from our sponsor better help
you know i really did not do anything
with my life until i got my mental
health in order i thought you're gonna
say until you met me
[Laughter]
like i just
prioritizing mental health is so
important you pretty much can't be your
full self and reach your full potential
unless you're putting that first and if
you
you kind of need to do maintenance ahead
of time too because you'll get burnt out
but you don't realize your burnout until
it's too late and you're screaming yeah
at a cashier at the apple store
well it's really burnout is so sneaky
and i think that it compromises your
role
in all parts of your life as a parent as
a friend as a partner to yourself yeah
that's why we're so excited to be
talking today about better help which is
online therapy that reminds you to
prioritize yourself better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to drive and park and add
in more stressful things you can do this
all from the comfort and safety of your
own home your own bed your own car if
you live with your parents at times and
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com trash tuesday
that's better h-e-l-p dot com slash
trash tuesday this isn't an exaggeration
every room in my house has the helix
mattress even the bathroom even the
bathroom and you guys every birthday
ever my mom's birthday sis everyone in
my family has a helix mattress i i love
it so much i've gifted it to everyone in
my life listen we spend a lot of time on
our backs as humans as women truthfully
i love that they have a sleep quiz so
they're actually taking your information
asking you the right questions and then
prescribing you the right mattress for
you and ever since we got ours i feel
like i just it it works for both of us
which is nice we love it are you guys
starfish so are we
find the right helix for your i'm a side
sleeper so i run really hot and i sleep
on my side so i was matched with the
midnight mattress but on top of that you
have the option to upgrade to the luxe
version of that which is such a dream
cloud to sleep on
listen i myself sleep face down ass up
so
it's really nice it's very easy on the
neck very nice in the knees i just think
it makes sense to
use a mattress from somewhere where they
have different options like it's not a
one size fits all it's like it's
actually tailored to your body your
needs and that to me is why i choose
helix and like you said like for friends
and family it comes right to your door
you just unbox it it does all of the
work by itself and helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com trash tuesday not only is
helix the bomb but they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk free they'll even
pack it up for you if you don't love it
but you will visit helixleep.com trash
tuesday to get up to two hundred dollars
off your helix mattress plus two free
pillows
[Music]
i have a brother you have a brother of
course i have a brother of course
younger or older i'm sorry you have such
a only child vibe
i mean really yeah my brother thinks
that too how was your brother how much
you're younger he's younger than you two
and a half years younger wow you're the
older he's a good kid
he's a searcher my brother turned out to
be the guy that he was very i remember
he was he was a tennis pro for years
like that was his thing no but he was
also very huggy and was always looking
for like that
yeah
he's uh you know and he talks he's he's
all right he landed on his feet he's
doing good yeah but he's a tennis guy
like my whole life he went to nick
boleteri's tennis institute and he was
trying to be a professional and all
through college he played and then he
opened a tennis school and now i i'm not
even clear what his job is but he's
working and he's got a nice girlfriend
is that how your family feels about your
job no my family's okay with my job do
they listen to your podcast yet my dad
figured out how but i think it was his
wife who figured out how because my
dad's in the beginning stages of
dementia and i think she just likes to
sit him somewhere but he never listened
to it i swore 1300 episodes he had no
idea
had no idea how to do it and i've been
on for a decade yeah and he had never
listened it's like
how do you do it i'm like you just put
the website up and you hit the play
button but he couldn't do it and now
like she's they're they're listening so
he's sitting there listening i don't
know if he remembers though it's a sad
time to begin with he can play he can
play the same episodes over and over
again well maybe he'll remember me
longer than
yeah the rest of the or maybe he won't
know you as a son but somebody actually
admires that's right exactly
you got a good shot yeah no he actually
admires me that's the weird thing it's
like you know especially when you have a
a weird i have a it's always been kind
of a competitive relationship but at
some point with your dad really at some
point it gave way and he realized like
he couldn't really [ __ ] with me anymore
i know nothing about this uh yeah like
what were your parents like how do they
how how does one create a market wow
this is her just saying i've never
listened to your podcast she doesn't
know anything about your parents i know
a lot about those parents
oh my my mother was my my mother was
like 22 when she had me and my dad was
like 25 and he was you know my dad was a
surgeon oh my god carlos
carlos's parents also had him at that
age and his dad's a surgeon what kind of
surgeon cancer
general cancer
cancer women yeah a woman cancer yeah
surgeon
that's what i call it
yeah i don't really know the official
name so he's uh
uh okay
my dad was orthopedic just saws and and
hammers cool
yeah no not rarely life threatening
that's crazy to want to do it takes a
particular type of personality to have
that exactness to be an orthopedic
surgeon yeah it takes an incredibly kind
of mega maniacal
narcissistic exactly because as dr drew
says like you know assets and
liabilities you want your fighter jet
pilot to be a narcissist honestly i
would want my orthopedic surgeon to be
equally as narcissistic
may not want your dad to be not the dad
yeah
i don't know but they did something
right i mean after a certain point you
kind of you know take what you got and
you you realize like there are some good
things and yeah the
i wasn't brought up in want of anything
and that covers a lot i feel like um
i've been thinking about this a lot like
because my dad is 81 80 i think you met
my parents oh he's only a couple years
younger than yeah
mine were not 25 when they had me
they're going to be this old age when
they have kids
um but my dad uh
he remembers everything and it's like
kind of hard because he feel so much
guilt about like verbally abusing us and
stuff when we were kids but we all
turned out so well like i have no anger
towards them anymore i really like did
all my work i needed to do with who with
my parents oh you sat down with them you
didn't do it with a you didn't process
it with it
but i've done my work like on them for
myself you know and i don't i'm not mad
at them at all like i don't even really
get triggered by them
um but my dad still has like the guilt
and i'm like dude just like evening of
life like enjoy your life we all my
brother both of my brothers have great
families and great jobs i have a great
job maybe that's just something that he
needs yeah i love the sound of that the
evening of life yeah i know i'm like
look at some trees
yeah that's beautiful i like i used to
my i used to fight with my dad like
crazy it's so interesting you were
competitive with your dad which must
come from him having you so young and
you guys being close in age like i can't
imagine being competitive with a parent
well i did i think it wasn't like you
know we weren't doing sports or anything
but i just i just think that brother
yeah exactly but i think it was his
refusal to acknowledge what i do like
when you have a guy that is so
self-centered it you know to get through
to land something you know in you know
in their mind it's kind of
you know well that's weird with comedy
too in my generation of comedy
specifically like if they don't see you
on television they don't know what
you're doing i thought you were talking
about your generation they had
television back then yeah they did yeah
jokes are fun they are
i know they're going to hurt me they're
going to really hurt me
but like i remember one time not that
long ago my dad like he's like maybe you
ought to talk to bill maher about you
know how to you know get a like
by the way have you seen his podcast no
i can't i can't do him anymore you would
feel i didn't do him that much to begin
with but he's something that shifted
with that guy yeah well the podcast is
why what is it why what's he just it's
like the way he's dressing everything
he's doing yeah with the new guys going
to his basement yeah the glasses he
needs like a help no somebody did help
him that's the problem i think
he's just older than him that helped him
i don't know what happened but i think
that's what he's going for is like this
um he's sick and tired of being this so
he would rather just go completely
opposite yeah i know but when you're a
[ __ ] baby boomer whatever shift
you're making is not gonna be great yeah
do you know what i mean unless it's
something more relaxed and something
giving up like
but like if you're a baby boomer going
like the thing it's time for those boots
it's not going to go well maybe that's
what giving up looks like for bill maher
i think i think it's maybe but to us
there's a balance
i think this is his final you know this
is it he's you know all of them think
it's a [ __ ] nightmare because like
i'm the tail end of the baby room i'm
not really a baby boom so like the egos
of the baby boomers is why the world is
ending and they like it's like they need
to get the [ __ ] out of the way
yeah not not get new glasses
that is funny my dad loves bummer every
dad loves bill maher everyone's dad
loves belmont well he does have like or
i haven't seen it in a while but he does
have both sides on which is fun i like
watching the debates of the both sides
yeah i like us i think that i'm hardcore
trumper
[Laughter]
i think that being a boomer is quite
possibly a state of mind because i've
met people younger than you
that um have very like big boomer energy
um very like antiquated thinking just
kind of never really you know stayed
with the times do you just mean like
angry comics
racists hate women middle-aged white
dudes
yeah yeah it was so i went to i was in
cleveland doing shows
and i got i've been to the rock and roll
hall of fame before but you know that
guy invited me again and it's like you
know the struggle of that place not just
to be like a hard rock that's huge
but uh but when i went in there and i
saw the men who were wandering around
the rock and roll hall of fame i'm like
i'm not one of these guys
i can't you know just with their tie-dye
shirts you know and it's just like i
can't be this isn't who i am right it's
just like classic hits personified just
people i i and i i'm not i'm not that
guy like i cut my own cutoffs do you
have a record collection i bought this i
bought this shirt wait did you really
cut those yourself wow
hot girl
energy yeah cut these myself what else
was i supposed to do
you did a great job yeah i tried to cut
my own shorts forever and i never get
them right how did you get him so frayed
that can we do that he's been here
longer than us
i don't know how doesn't it just happen
naturally the fraying i don't think i
did a thing so there was a recollect
you just took some apparently it's
tricky though it's tricky but you know
and you guys
you gals i mean you can cut them shorter
these are might be arguably a little
short for me but i like them they're
short i like them where's they're good
me
carlos is like a bee
i do wear short shorts i know we saw you
yesterday i mean last week we had a
baywatch themed episode mark my mom just
like i see pictures of me and my mom i
don't know what she wanted for me but my
mom was always kind of hip but there's
pictures of me in literally a purple hot
pants outfit
like with purple and white short shorts
and a purple and white tank top with a
star on it and like what was going on
there it turned into a star i guess her
doll it was like it was yeah it was like
early 70s [ __ ] yeah like a david bowie
type looking i don't know i think she
just was groovy like i remember like
there was like some vest pictures you
know and some like bell-bottom pictures
and
yeah yeah was she the creative spirit in
your head yeah she was a painter and you
know she's still kind of that she paints
and does does she live in albuquerque
she lives in florida florida is your dad
in albuquerque yes yes as far as he kind
of knows yet
imagine like just choosing never mind
sorry albuquerque is choosing to live
there forever i thought i was looking at
places i was going to go back but then
santa face zone i like santa it's cute
right and i i grew up there but it's
also on fire so we really need to get
away from the places that burn every
year and maybe find places
by careful of the care crashes i've
gotten real nervous about that so i
don't want to be
i want to get out before the the freak
out about no water happens i don't want
to be stuck in traffic you know heading
east with everyone else in los angeles
you think it's going to go like that
it's going to be like uh
well i mean i don't know what we know
and what we're telling what we're being
told and also where you get your
information i'm just not getting the
info i'm just gonna be like chilling you
know what's really creepy hold on to
that uh liquid death that's all i'm
saying if you're getting it this is
what's gonna save us yeah this is you're
gonna need the liquid death so if you've
got the i've got like 40 cases of that
[ __ ] that's good just in case no they
keep sending it oh yeah yeah
i'm not doing it on purpose
people come over and it's embarrassing
it's like what's going on i'm like just
take something yeah are you all right
yeah
when i've been um spearfishing in lake
mead you can see where the water line
used to be and it's like stories and
stories high
and it's so you know you hear about it
but then you're like eh whatever there's
still water there but then you actually
go there and you see how much water
we're missing and you're like
but this is the other side of belief
right the thing we were talking about
before you want to believe stuff most of
what we're doing to get by is total
magical thinking
right i mean like that's the reality of
it but we're like we're okay right
aren't we i mean i think i was going no
i was like what's a syllable sure
exactly
exactly you just
the powerlessness of it is so like
overwhelming you sort of just have to be
like i think i'm okay i'm showering less
time
that's gonna help i know sometimes i'm
like should i have kids or not no
yeah i know why thank you for saying
that why
i know how do you dispense your life
however long that's going to be or
theirs and that for that point
convincing them of what i got i mean i
got nothing against kids but i don't
know what the conversations are
that you have with them to make them
believe that everything's going to be
okay i mean that's your primary
objective as a [ __ ] parent is to like
you know take care of the kid and make
them think that it's going to be okay
try that try me
make me think everything's going to be
okay annie um go to sleep little one
it's nap time little one hungry
come have a suckle
but maybe i'm being cynical maybe i i
mean i don't know no not you
do you know what joke of yours i always
think of as when you're like i had you
had to get an ultrasound on your heart
and you're like surprised it's a girl
i love that joke that's the funniest one
yeah yeah
that's my favorite marriage and i say i
kind of knew
i don't know why they're just gonna
laugh i mean i think
i think people like because i did it for
a while i enjoy it you put it on a
special i saw it on special was it yeah
um but uh but like a a cardiologist said
you know people make the baby joke all
the time but like but that's not the
joke the joke that it mine's a girl
girl heart of course yeah no people get
it yeah they just don't they're not
moved to laugh they're thinking about it
they're going that's true he is he's a
real [ __ ] girl yeah exactly i don't
know if they say it like that but thank
you are you are you still mad at your
ex-wife for have you gotten through that
oh mishna yeah no i'm not mad and it
hasn't been i kind of let that go it
kind of she did a kind of a great thing
after about a decade of my anger like i
used to
did you know her you didn't know i never
let her know
excuse me i used to uh i used to email
she got me sober really you know and i
used to email her every year
on my uh sober birthday to thank her for
getting me sober it was the only time i
would email her yeah but you know this
is after a year it's just
we it was horrible but it went on for i
just kept doing it and uh
just once a year and just trashing her
on your podcast on the i i don't i
stopped doing that i don't know if i ca
i trashed her i was trying to be
diplomatic i think i was ultimately
looking
to connect with her somehow yeah you
know i i haven't even run into her yeah
yeah that's so frustrating 15 years yeah
because you run into people that like if
this were new york you'd be running into
everybody yeah but for some reason
people in l.a once they find their
pocket that they're there so if you're
not going into that world you're not
going to see them but anyway so every
year on
august 19th or 9th or whatever
thank you you know despite whatever
thank you for giving and then the for
some reason the last time i did it she
just wrote uh back she said if i want to
hear from you i'll let you know oh she
married you
well kinda but like i then i realized
like oh my god i'm that guy where you
know the email comes in and she's like
oh [ __ ] yeah she has it on her calendar
like oh it's her like it's her the worst
day of her year not even just you don't
want to be that guy who shows up on a
phone we all have those people where
you're like why does this person keep
doing this yeah that's actually she
that's a great comeback i'm gonna steal
that from her sure it was boundaries
what is it gonna be oh i have a couple
people that i need to use that on a
former lawyer a former friend you know
as your former lawyer and friend
i just remembered i forgot to tell you
guys this i so i went on um family
vacation to long
long beach island and my boyfriend
wasn't with me i was just with my
nephews and my older brother and my
parents and at that we went to the like
county fair
and at the fair i ran into my
ex-boyfriend's
best friend the rollerblader yes
the rollerblader yes and it was so weird
i was like hey guys because i have no
interest in like any sort of unhealthy
yeah uh x stuff so i didn't bring them
up at all like i wasn't like how is it
because it's not my business anymore
like we're good
i i'm assuming he's happy
and uh hopefully he is but i just was
like
hey and then it was like it was there
was like 10 seconds of just like staring
at each other and she just went okay
thanks for coming over yeah i have a
question about that in regards to social
media um do you when you break up with
somebody do you then unfollow or
unfriend all of their family members is
that the rule i wasn't following any of
them and i on what social media like
like you know like the i don't know they
love
or i pretty much don't let go of anyone
so they're gonna have to unfollow me
first
like really yeah i don't i think that's
so mean to like unfollow someone that
you had a connection with because you
dated someone like i would not unfollow
but i think i'm rude i don't follow
friends yeah because it's sort of like
enough already dude
okay so we're here to educate you about
the new manscaped 2.0 boxer briefs and
here's what i'm going to say okay the
micro model fabric is buttery soft and
breathable keeping you
cool as a cucumber
and you know where what's amazing is you
can choose from an arrangement of
designs and colors and these boxer
briefs i know dave has been wearing them
they're perfect he loves them you guys
i'm at a boat harbor somewhere in dana
point i'm going diving today which means
i have to be in a boat which means that
i have to be
in a swimsuit and because i'm a
considerate human being and i want to
present to society correctly or
considerately guess what i did this
morning i took the lawnmower 4.0 from
manscape and i did a nice little
friendly trim and this summer i want you
guys to do the same you guys this is the
best electric trimmer on the market it
has a really cool led light which i need
for precision
and on top of that it's waterproof you
guys can get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code trash at manscaped.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the go trash at manscape.com again
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code trash at manscape.com
[Music]
i mean i posted a picture of me on the
toilet yesterday which is really good
it just was a funny picture sorry i
couldn't help but i had my big time i
love hot girl on toilet pictures i feel
like guys really or don't like it
i mean i don't know if i've ever sought
them out maybe i gotta
let me do some research it does remind
me of like you just look up hot girl on
toilet no can you bring that up on the
screen look it up because they
definitely have that of course yeah yeah
there's guys that are always in our
comments trying to give us get us to
give each other wedgies like they
obviously have like a wedgie fetish
but how far do you how like
like once you see it do you look at nine
pictures of wedgies i mean what is a
fetish like that what do they think they
like to see the wedgie it's probably the
oh dude and the face i'm sure i'm
assuming oh the the weird the moment of
pain but i don't but i'm just guessing i
have no clue
i don't have that i'm not a real fetish
guy so like i don't quite understand it
the reason that i love posing on a
toilet is that it gives me the illusion
of big hips
that's me texting kala when i had them
on the toilet and i'll tell you exactly
what the text is a miscarriage or just
my period that's i know exactly what the
text is esther
it's usually at two in the morning and
it's let's build wealth
whenever i want to get esther to
sometimes on stage i'll try to call
esther and she won't pick up and then
i'll go what should i say to her that'll
get her to pick up and i go
um
something about money
pick up and then she picks up financial
opportunity ahead
i was i think i was like i have memories
and there there were two times i've
accidentally like at a restaurant
walked into a bathroom and there was a
woman peeing in there like it was this
moment like i remember it was it viselka
once in new york yeah and it was just an
accident that's a small bathroom too
yeah but the look on her face was so
humiliated that like i came everywhere
yeah
and i felt bad because i kept standing
there no no i just she was just wiping
her face it was tears
i like i felt so embarrassed and and
mortified that the memories is in my
head i think it's not a good memory i
think i just feel like i bet i'm sorry i
embarrassed her i think it's more
embarrassing for the person walking in i
do too i think that's probably true yeah
because i have
my queening lady walked in i'd be like
oh dude it was like just the worst
because
i'll tell you exactly what was happening
please
she's there today but like
i mean you're like she still works yeah
yeah yeah but no i wasn't i was in my
bathroom upstairs and i had gotten like
from doing sit-ups i'd gotten like a
thing on my uh top of my ass crack like
you know where you like like that kind
of yeah
um so i was like putting i was literally
putting cream on that when she walked in
and you kind of had to so just
well yeah i'm kind of standing there
putting ointment on my ass and she's
like oh i'm sorry i'm like no no i
wasn't no it was just ointment i
wouldn't
come back in i just showed you the whole
thing
i'm not doing anything weird
i'm just like can you do this for me
walking getting walked in on is
definitely like something that i feel
like you let it happen you once and then
you learn how to never have it happen
again right and getting embarrassed
getting walked in on but depends what
you're doing like if i wouldn't want
anyone to walk in on me well because i
don't have any toilet shame if you walk
in on me while i'm peeing whatever i
don't care
yeah yeah never close i have moments of
just deep depression in the shower just
with my tits hanging on like both sides
like deep thought like just a 1000 yard
stare that's when i don't want anyone
watching because i'm not standing
straight i'm just like in this slump all
of us are like maybe we do have a fetish
always like huh
the thing i remember about that that
horrible moment is how horrified this
woman was in vaselink and there's a
million years ago but she always she was
also in that i because i saw her come
out because you got to deal with that
that sort of like yeah
yeah i'm sorry it's my favorite she was
like total kind of like at that time it
was probably the 80s like punk rock
aggressive feminism kind of person and
i'm like what a [ __ ] nightmare for
that person for just some dude to watch
i projected a lot but i decided to feel
like uh
horrendous about it for decades well
hopefully she's listening i think she's
all right i think she'll be all right
mark is here to apologize to you mark
are you into bananas i haven't eaten a
banana in a long time i got i got walked
in on someone told me they're just all
sugar
[Applause]
[Music]
i think my mom uh walked down me on me
jerking off when i was in high school
probably but how how's that not gonna
happen cause you're just constantly
jerking off really when you're in high
school yeah that happened to me too it
did my uh and they know they already
know like i mean what do they think that
like mound of kleenex shoved onto your
bed i know what it is of course my mom i
came home from school once and my mom
was like your brother's been
masturbating so much i found all these
crunchy socks she's like the toilet
paper's gone crunchy socks how's that
not the title of something
it's a podcast
trevor it's about trevor wallace shout
out
um
i'm mike
blaustein right mm-hmm
um
blaustein
yeah i like him he's cool but i wanted
to make sure he said his name because
trevor is more successful than him so i
wanted to get his name in there too we
gotta rise up we gotta
rise you up i got walked in i was living
on my friend's couch
and he walked in on me and goes what are
you masturbating and i really was
[ __ ] embarrassing and then one time
he sat down he was like is this your
[ __ ] vibrator on my ass i'm like
maybe can i tell you guys a horror story
yes i have never told i don't think i've
even told bobby but i had double
pneumonia at 17 and i was hot in a
hospital for
um i was an arcadia methodist for about
two weeks like i didn't really end with
you getting raped
i'm bored no but
it's the only time i've ever been
embarrassed to
get walked in on and it was because i
was i had missed a dance i was still in
the hospital i was really fat from all
the prednisone i was really hungry and
my
stepbrother came to visit
i'm a brother [ __ ] mark
yeah i'm just watching fetishes develop
in mark's
so my step brother comes to visit and
you're all weak and i'm just waiting for
everything and you're bloated but it's
like juicy but i'm really in her rage
because that's what steroids yes i mean
they make you moon-faced and angry and i
was getting all of these like breathing
treatments and i'm like i'm bored i'm
supposed to be at a dance and he came
over to see me and i was like hey will
you just [ __ ] me
and he did and then the nurse came in
and then her supervisor had to have a
talk with me and like reprimand me
and it was a whole thing and i honestly
i i'm sweating so much just saying this
because that's the only true feeling of
like shame i've had about being walked
in on because i was [ __ ] my brother
at a hospital was that the first time
you [ __ ] your brother
no but it was maybe like
maybe like the third time but i mean he
was a very like sweet meek boy he he's
he's past you know he killed himself at
not too long after
oh my god i'm laughing but
and it grows the fetish no i think it
just died you saw the full arc of the
fetish
the full life cycle of a fetish just
grew and it died in within five minutes
i'm sorry about the hot thing there is
like you're in the hospital and of
course that's the part you like
you fake sick gave yourself munchausen
you have munchkin houses
i once walked in on a woman i was uh
with at some time who jerked off like
with the water and i once walked in on
her [ __ ] the faucet yeah it was
pretty exciting
or it doesn't like stuck on or well no
yeah she was like she liked the
removable shower heads but if they
weren't there she would get out
yeah
under the faucet come on
no oh yeah don't make it too hot don't
make it too cold either
like to walk in on someone doing that
whoa okay a lot of work going on there i
gotta i'm sorry you're trying not to
drown she had to snorkel on
[Music]
[Laughter]
someone commented i know we shouldn't
read comments but i did read them
someone was like can they stop joking
about being molested no [ __ ] we can't
are you serious that's our that's our
thesis statement
that's her dissertation everybody was
molested
in different ways except esther but i
feel like um mentally she's been
over the years
thank you
problems
we call her our resident molester
no my most epic uh telling of my
molester tutorial was on your podcast
yes oof as like a long it was like an
involved narrative it was crazy
but then i got over it
yeah
now
yeah i keep trying to think if i was
molested
yeah because um there was
i remember one week you're cutting those
shorts pretty short i know yeah i know
it's a sign i know it is i know i read
about it
no it was uh that when we were kids me
and my brother when we lived in alaska
my dad was in the military
and um
[Music]
let some sergeant's son babysit us like
i had a series of weird babysitters and
i do remember him like suggesting to me
and my brother and he took his dick out
and [ __ ] but like it's sort of kind of
like i don't recall doing anything yeah
and but i kind of recall i'm sort of
like like maybe my brother did but i
don't think i you know kind of throw
tennis seems like he's getting some like
molested aggravation out but like there
was just a series of babysitters there
was a couple of women too that took
their boobs out like i remember yeah it
was crazy i hear that a lot from my male
friends and from their babysitters
yeah because i remember that one of my
friends um tj he was like yeah the first
time i'd ever seen like hairy tits on a
woman was when i was a child and my
babysitter would be like look at my tits
like my tits and i was like i think
that's not appropriate he was like are
you sure he was like i was fine with it
at that time i was like yeah i don't
think i don't i don't think she was
doing you a favor i remember there was a
babysitter that said like picked up this
huge book
like me and my brother we must have been
i must have been like you know under 10
like it must been seven that would have
been enough to traumatize me don't make
me read
and she just picks up this huge book and
she goes i don't feel anything when i
read
like and i remember we like we undressed
her kind of
after she said that yeah because that's
sort of what she wanted she was just
sort of like
like go ahead oh my god and uh and i
remember these weirdos whoa wait i'm
gonna try that in bed i don't feel
anything when i read i remember i was
like hooking up with this guy once and i
was like wasted and i was like i was
like i want to suck your dick at the
library this was i don't know why but i
was like what i go what book would you
read if i sucked your dick at the
library and he said the bible and it was
actually pretty funny i gotta answer the
bible corinthians
my friend tyson what's up
i'm just sad now that i never had
babysitters oh you never had a baby
little babies you were a babysitter no i
had i was but i had a babysitter only
literally once it's because i had an
older sister
and so i just she was just always up in
her room when i was by myself is that
why you were kept in a crate yes most of
the time it's why i'm so lonely
forever
it's nice they poked the holes though
for you to breathe thank you yeah the
sweetest part no it was i was gated in
to my room i wasn't created i had a um i
had a babysitter who big difference guys
he brilliantly different he i remember
his pants were unzipped yeah so he had
um he had jeans on his pants weren't
zipped and there was no underwear and me
and my brothers i don't know if he had
fallen asleep jerking off or something
because i know my parents like later on
i found out that my parents had fired a
couple babysitters because they kept
stealing their porns
or they would leave them in oh so they
were like jerking off to my parents
porns like while they were babysitting
us yeah
the decency to
spiderman it out with your jizz but um
so
then uh we went to the kitchen and we
got ice and we put ice in his
so it kind of feels like we took back
the night i don't know
you know when i first came here from um
the philippines they had promised me
because i was molested by a family
member in the philippines that was the
first molestation so when i came to
america i had spent my childhood
watching rescue 9-1-1 in the philippines
so i was like america's got authority
figures and nothing bad is going to
happen to me there and my first mta bus
ride on a 483 down fair oaks a man
across from me on like the disabled seat
put his dick between a book and then
just started moving his book like this
and then maybe i i've had
like subway jerker offers
on behalf of our country they have so
much she was like i'm sorry did you
think your book molester story was good
have you ever heard of the bookmark move
okay
it was just this illusion of like safety
was what i was gonna find in this brand
new land and then just people could not
stop jerking off in buses i'm like what
the [ __ ] is that and now you're dating
the opposite of a cop bobby lee
[Laughter]
wow yeah no flasher stuff is so weird
because i i got
i had a guy um
drive by me when i was running pretty
recently this was like kind of like
still got it um and he like creeped i
looked over and he was jerk out but his
dick was flaccid and it was like there
was like an insult added to it where he
wasn't hard but he was just beating his
like and you felt you had to work harder
yeah i was like
i guess i should run faster
any hint of a guy going soft on me i'm
out that room saying i do not want to
see it all coming down i don't want to
be around your shame i don't want the
explanation i'm like you do okay bye
it's not me it's not me
i love that like you just pick up your
things you don't like the the common
apology i not only do i not like the
common apology i don't want to even sit
there and attempt to get you back up i'm
like you know what because then i'm
going to take on the shame of being like
that was me
it's hard to not take it on yeah
yeah but either you know what i did i
started what if he said like it's not
you i just don't really like you could
you help me
can you can you talk at a lower register
talk a little lower voice
i i always i turned it into um
i'm just so hot they can't get their
dick up what i don't know i hate that
you know what look back i'm just so high
you can't handle
i yeah i know sometimes i'm like not
obviously a todd but with other guys
where i've just been like trying really
hard to imagine there's someone else
when they start talking i'm like
you're [ __ ] ruining this
really yeah where you're just so sick of
the person you're buying you're like oh
trying to think about the guy at the gas
station
the guy at the gas station
i've never had that like i've never
really thought about a person in life i
feel like that's more i wouldn't be a
person i know i would never like because
i do actually not
i'm just not like if i'm with someone
i'm not like thinking about like a
specific person yeah yeah that i see a
lot gotcha okay i remember when
before uh
that my second wife split before mission
split i remember specifically
uh knowing that she was completely
vacant when she was [ __ ] me how did
you know
because like i remember having talked to
her about something years before about
someone she had gone out with but i just
knew that like she just shut off to me
but she wasn't you know ready to split
yet like she wasn't in order so she was
still sort of playing along but i could
just see in her face she was very
delightful this wasn't like the no it
wasn't lifeless it was just sort of like
she was pretty enough
like she's beautiful like she's a really
beautiful person so like she was just
turning on yeah the power of the beauty
in my face and i'm like there was
nothing going on and it was like so
disturbing yeah it was it was it that
and the walking in on the punk girl the
bathroom people when people like don't
want to [ __ ] you and they're just doing
it to do it it feels bad i think i i'm
with you there i mean i understand it in
retrospect yeah i mean i guess we've all
kind of done it yeah
yes
definitely three times i've ever had
yeah sometimes i'm like you could really
probably like take a picture of my face
right now and i could get cast as like
one of those corpses on
svu like i am not with us here staircase
season two
this year are you watching that thing
yeah are you i didn't watch it now okay
yeah i'm trying to watch that uh
severance
i know it's hard i keep falling asleep
yeah it's a little tiring i like that
it's making me anxious yeah yeah not in
a good way it's just sort of like i get
it there's hallways don't you watch this
if you cut out the hallways that'd be
like three episodes did you say we
crashed no what's that i like that about
with the wii work
and jared leto plays oh yeah
is it good acting i love her he actually
was kind of great like they were i
really liked it he like
he's pretty good and halfway i love her
so much when i met her like i was like
beside myself really tell people people
turned on her
people turned on her on the um when her
and james franco were hosting the oscars
because they saw too much of the like
act she would be like well that's
because he [ __ ] her
yeah he [ __ ] her over yeah
so he wasn't pissed the whole time yeah
well no he did a bit he dismissed this
the the ceremony so he was going to just
pretend like it was [ __ ] but she
wasn't in on the joke so he kind of left
her hanging oh i see that makes so much
sense yeah i don't remember that what
happened he just like he just
condescended the entire oscar thing and
they were co-hosting he's like i'm just
trying to get my dick sucked by a
seventeen allegedly
allegedly yeah he was just you know
dismissive of the whole thing in his
attitude but she wasn't in on it and she
was trying to do the job and now i want
to write watching clips because i bet
you it was more like her being like
probably yeah but i just always loved
her i don't know why there's some shiny
people like i've met in my life but i
liked her before that i had a crush on
her i can't explain it did you ever have
her on your show i did yeah and i one
time i saw her in new york before i had
her on my show and you know i was not
nobody but close but i remember i i just
saw her and there was just that moment
like i should go say and i'm like it's
just how is that going to go like she
doesn't know me i'm just going to be
another one of those idiots like hey you
know i really um wow okay you know like
you have to like name drop like your
best credits you have to be like um you
have to do a quick oh there she is yeah
the old house yeah who are other shiny
shiny people who else is shiny oh mandy
moore is one of the shiniest people i've
ever seen she seems real shiny
like in terms of like one-on-one with
with shiny people when she walked up to
my house i was like what the where did
this person come from like she landed
from something yeah and she brought
cookies and some people yeah you're like
how are you allowed to talk to me
exactly yeah like we're not the same
species what are you there's some shiny
dudes too there's look at her yeah she's
definitely shiny i'm trying to think of
something like that
josh brolin's pretty pretty shy oh yeah
i've seen how much he was in he lives in
or he was in santa fe for real uh
all the time that guy's just like can
the charm situation with that guy's
pretty intense
oh ray leota how was that one great we
might have killed him we accidentally
killed him we were just brought him up
we brought him up and then he died
yeah do you guys have that power there's
because there's three of you yeah yeah
we said we functioned we thought he was
hot which crap circle yeah did you
remember what drinking was back in the
day sure i kind of did wait mark what
kind of drunk were you
uh i in high school i was pretty sloppy
yeah but as i got older um
it uh i was balancing it with blow so
you know i wasn't like a constant
blackout drinker but i was just sort of
like uh bloated and sweaty and
aggravated and uh real cirrhosis
blackout i don't know if i was
i just was i kind of mixed it up but i i
definitely was um
every day
well i mean it was doing stand up it was
i think i hit the the bottom in new york
so i mean it was like at least four or
five days a week did you ever do like
the same jokes accidentally drunk on
stage look if you
there were some places where you would
do two or three shows and you didn't
know so i don't know that i did that but
there were certainly nights where i did
the same joke or i started the same joke
twice and i'm like did i yeah
i'm so afraid i'm always like
sometimes i'm neither of you
no
never
and they're just all looking at you and
i'm like what happens like you just did
that yeah and then you're like oh thank
god i thought you just hated my jokes
much better i just it was a it was a
comic error to me it's like such an
ultimate form of humiliation because
everyone else knows and you're standing
there it just seems so you know it's an
ultimate form of humiliation doing stand
up
agree
firmly agree yeah what is this job we do
but there used to be nights were on the
road where you have to do three shows on
a saturday so by the third show you're
like out of your [ __ ] mind like did i
do you have to qualify everything he's
like did i do the one about i didn't
right okay here it is
well it's like if i'm like when i was in
san francisco
by the last show i was so [ __ ] tired
just because i was like having so much
fun up so late yeah did you ever have a
relationship with weed
yeah every day um yeah it was just like
constant i mean i always had weed
i loved it woke up had weeds all day had
a little one-hitter i ca i still have my
little dumb pipe
and the little wooden case i used to
keep my weight maybe um you know i know
you always want you always wish a
grandparent would hand you down like an
airline
this is this weird almost looks like a
handmade wooden pipe and back in in new
york you're just you tuck into phone
booths from their phone booths but now
everything's legal it's so weird i know
but you just said i was always like in
phone booths
wait that is crazy to think that when
you were smoky weed it was illegal and
you had to hide it
well if you go to texas you have to like
i you just like go into corners and
stuff and i when i was smoking weed and
i was in texas i would smoke like a
little bit in the bathroom but then it's
like if you get caught smoking it's like
so [ __ ] expensive new york it's you
the entire city smells like weed now
like everywhere smells like weed in new
york whoa
isn't the weed really strong are people
because like yes pot will [ __ ] you up
i don't know i mean you have no
reference because you never smoked in
high school you just got into it yeah
yeah yeah i guess you have different
strains and degrees of stuff you can
kind of manage it a little bit for me
it's intolerable compared to this [ __ ]
that i used to smoke in high school
because you had to smoke a lot back then
now it's like the tiniest but i had to
call it i called 911 on myself the last
time i took another oh i love that i
love it it was amazing
because she wanted it she thought it was
gonna be rescue 9-1-1 she was used to
seeing that as a kid america is safe
they've got me they come
um i i took an edible i went to sleep
this was a couple years ago and i woke
up in the middle of the night thinking
that i was in full blood cardiac arrest
she has heart problems i have heart
problems
what kind
i have an arrhythmia and
i had a procedure done about five years
ago where they go in through my femoral
artery and then they take these little
radio frequency things and they burn off
abnormal tissue in my heart wow and then
you just go home that same day yeah so
it's cute but you're fixed then were you
depressed after ish
it still has a heart surgery my dad got
that well what happened i was depressed
because i started getting worse and
worse episodes immediately after which i
wasn't told would happen but um
yeah you just you just go home it's kind
of [ __ ] cool how that works it's like
okay there you go we
you know but heart stuff [ __ ] with you
because the hearts
dude previous to that i didn't go out
for two years because i had a full
mistrust of my body i was you know an
athlete my whole life i was division one
swimmer and all of a sudden your heart's
like hey just kidding [ __ ] like we're
no longer gonna beat correctly for you
and so i had a mistrust in my body i
thought every tiny feeling was heart
related i was like over checking my
little symptoms i would go to gelsen's
and have a panic attack at the produce
aisle
and yeah like things like that but after
i got there
just in general
i went to the cardiologist i get and
there's a thing i have a thing what is
it i want to know the thing
uh i guess i'm not sure what the name
for i always had uh i had a little
plaque i knew that because i went and
got a plaque tested and i think it was
from smoking my most of my life
but uh but now i've got like one of my
valves it has a little backwash on the
beach it's a little murmur
it's not a murmur a little backwards way
they say about it but it's just they're
like um all right and i'm like so what
do i got to do he's like well you're my
heart rate's really low my blood
pressure is always up cause i'm in good
shape he's like well you exercise
without him right yeah he's like we'll
just keep doing that and i'm like okay
yeah the [ __ ] am i gonna do like it's my
heart yeah you freak out yeah but a
little you know a little backwash
now was your dad uh healthy
my dad was nuts i had hypo i was a
hypochondriac all my life but i think
that was one of the resolutions that i
kind of made with my old man's i
realized that the reason i was a
hypochondriac it was because that's how
i could get attention from my old man
because he was a doctor
sorry this very weird thing
about hypo i i tell a huge long story
about how my hypochondria was resolved
that involves a urologist that my dad
knew
audrey whose son just came to see me why
are urologists what was happening
oh well the stuff
well it's so i've told him many times
but like it was one of these situations
where
you know i was freaking out of college
and i kept calling my dad and i kept
calling him and saying i got prostate
cancer he's like you don't and i'm like
no it's like my i don't know i feel like
my balls and my ass kind of like it's
like i think i have prostate cancer dad
take a look yeah well that's sort of
where it goes right so i'm like he's
like you don't i just kept driving them
nuts like with this prostate cancer so
when i got home
i got i arrived at night and he's like
and i'm like i have the prostate cancer
my dad's like well i'm taking you see
bob rosen right now this is his friend
who's urologist that's the thing about
having a doctor dad you could see
doctors at any time yeah but this was
your dream come true carlos got the
vaccine before every elderly person in
the united states i got it in 2020
but this is awkward because now it's
nighttime we're driving the box you
haven't lost your balls we're driving to
bob rose you're getting to go to a
doctor's house at night yeah but he
doesn't like but but but for prostate
cancer
so we get to the door like the the cream
on the top of the yeah and this guy's
this guy's eating dinner with his family
and my dad's like my kid thinks he has
prostate cancer
exactly right exactly so we then i walk
in with my dad and bob rose and we're in
bob rose in his bedroom
and and he goes maybe we should do this
at the office i'm like yeah that maybe
that would be more appropriate
so we don't he doesn't finger bang me at
the house bless him yes you don't want
to be finger-banged by a doctor
unless it's at the office and he's
looking for prostate cancer
so maybe that's what your doctor was but
the build up the whole process of the
story is i get the finger banging i get
the food out of my dick and like it
turns out i have prostatitis which is a
stress infection
yeah so i get the medicine and then i go
through the medicine i'm home on
christmas break and after i run the
medicine i still think it i still think
i have it i'm like it still hurts a
little bit so i go back to bob i'm like
i don't think it went away and i kind of
make him finger bang me again
and he's like no it's gone and then like
the last uh like the last week i'm home
i decided i'd have herpes on my dick i
didn't even have sex yeah it's like a
jerk-off store or something so i go back
to bob and i show him my dick he's like
wow there is something there maybe we
should go to the hospital so we go the
hospital and then we go back to his
office and i swear to god this is after
a month of this [ __ ] rosen's holding my
dick looking at it and he looks up at me
and goes there's nothing wrong with you
do you like coming here
he like leans in for a kiss exactly and
that was that and then it went away it
kind of went away after that i'm like
maybe maybe that kind of attention is
not necessary well it was just the
embarrassment of like why am i here
every five minutes why do i constantly
go to the doctor you broke the seal of
having the finger banging and then
you're like
no i think maybe is there something to
like when you go and you find out
there's nothing wrong like that soothes
you so you want to keep going
sure there's that and it was just sort
of the repetition like now when i i'm
kind of i have to i had to build some
sort of strength around like if there's
something wrong with me it's like well
wait a couple days see what happens yes
but like younger me was like i gotta go
the emergency room i have had that so
drilled in my head by my parents it's
like you wait a while if you still have
that problem in a week in a month that's
not bleeding or something but you know
yeah
yeah
yeah we believe the opposite of that we
bleed a lot i know i'm so the opposite
of that it's like i pay a ridiculous
amount for health insurance for a ppo if
that's at my disposal with twenty
dollars copay i can have that peace of
mind i'm gonna go
i'll definitely go to the clinic i don't
like that bob hope clinic they have sag
after clinic yeah you can go there i
didn't have i didn't have health
insurance for so long that i have to
remind myself i have health insurance
because i'm so used to just brushing
anything off yeah like it's fine i'll
just [ __ ] know you've got to use it
get your physicals and all that [ __ ] if
you've got it again i have it but the
reason
i'm like this is because my mom used to
wait out when i was younger my sister
had like really bad asthma and my sister
would be having a full-blown asthma
attack cyanotic blue in the lips and
she'd be like i don't think you need
your hands oh my god so she would
withhold the inhaler from my sister and
see if my sister could get through it
just with a steam shower i don't know
did it has anyone said your mom was kind
of [ __ ] up my mom is uh [ __ ] up i i
love her very much today she is um
but but yeah i mean like she was that
type so i completely switched it it is
weird because our parents do listen to
our pa do our podcast
yeah but that's what it's like a reverse
my dad loves your podcast too that's
when i first got real clown with my dad
as well
yeah i go don't actually listen to it
though what are those these are yeezy
foam runners kanye west oh they're kind
of interesting yeah i have to pee are we
almost done yeah yeah
yeah we are we're good carlos go stick a
finger possess make sure you please
someone hold my dick while i pee
thank you so this was so this is great
thanks for coming thank you
brand new episode next week
you